boom we're live maybe maybe we're live
I think realize hello good morning
everybody well this looks I don't even
know we've got a real ramshackle
streaming setup going on so if
everything looks terrible it's cuz I'm
me and everything I do is terrible oh
there we go
hey that looks not too terrible well hey
how do you do I did pretty good there
hello everybody the we can see that okay
it's Christmas Eve to a barbecue raise
your hand okay so we are going to she's
a big girl yes I got bigger how much 150
I feel like she weighs more than that I
don't know because I mean I was just at
the gym this morning not to brag but I
dead lifted a hundred and thirty-five
[Laughter]
a huge dog maybe I'll have the bigger
growth
Oh a little air grow up yeah that must
be yeah definitely fifty pounds of
heroin tyloo che alright but that's
besides the point
oh we're here we're here to make soon
so if you've ever wanted to know how to
make blue bogey it's very easy now we
can't the camera is not wide enough able
to show everything here but we've got
carrots we've got onions
we've got bell peppers we've got
mushrooms
why didn't bro okay baby Bella
you can't you go to any store baby Bella
why dinner and the white and you're like
I don't like mushrooms but I like the
flavor of flavor got some green onions
leave you know the leek meme from way
too long right kills the fat cell which
doesn't sound like a good thing I think
that's actually bad okay so now and then
we got the beef celebrate the sliced
very sliced beef okay it called beef is
there any vegetarian version of or Goudy
like or something
does it need be
I'm sorry that's why that's can be
better eh okay yeah so for those of you
don't know a lot of Korean dishes are
actually vegetarian not a necessity
because when Koreans were like they're
starving like nice food we always stormy
what are you talking about only we stood
in years last 50 years okay so up until
just now all Koreans have been starving
according to my mom and that trust
everybody was kidding everybody was
sickening everybody onion I already said
oh yeah oh yeah what do you know yes
okay
my mom did all the hard work I'm gonna
take all the credit
Oh garlic garlic minced garlic don't
forget it very important okay nah brown
sugar is all must have sesame oil we
must make sure so we'll just has to be
real
sometime they smell imitation has to be
real Oh Thank You Cameron vigil what is
this aged soy sauce no not that young
baby soy sauce you want the old
crotchety grandpa's soy sauce
at least a hundred years later probably
been sitting up yeah yeah literally on
the back yard in the dirt you pull it up
out of the ground
whistles time what is it no don't tell
them what is this raise your hand
yes Derek you're right it's sesame seed
good job 20 points to Gryffindor what
else we got this would be C mm-hmm and
of course what is this salt salt sea
salt sea salt
yeah and also I've got this money you
don't have
lamb parents the parents
no reason mr. sauce the reason I wash or
to you is because you know she saw us
it's called fishy sauce for any of you
looking at the anchovies is trapped and
so we extract salt water flock toss and
something weird thing called anchovies
so Lea and Perrins is not Korean but you
know what I just bought this well two
more yesterday because if you don't have
this one it's either or not both Apple
you put both in whole thing blows up but
I rather use this one because it's Mike
we don't have this one you don't have
time to buy this one
how we get started I already watched
prepare everything watch this all that
we've been watched okay
okay so we're gonna do some good slicing
you know it's funny I can see where I
got my my proclivity and videos to
parrot
we got mushrooms or in Korean
[Laughter]
Korean ways of cooking hit everything as
hard as you can including the people
eating the food step 1
dump your me step 1 prepare your
vegetables step 1 step 2 wash let's do
it
step 3 wash good good good step 4 don't
trust we're gonna put a little cocaine
in there step 5 put a little extra you
know what and your ingredients step 6
dump the meat that's one that's barely
one serving oh it's about two servings
not one soul serving hey you stole my
job you popped it over I thought I was
the helper here
what's a weight here serving size 2
ounces 7 what's 2 times 7 everybody
little quiz here keep you on your toes
12 7 14 14 ounces what little less than
a pound 16 ounces in a pound so 2 of
them means 14 to 16 or 7
no no 14 eighths which is 1 and 3/4 of a
pound of meat yeah so get in step 7
measure out your meat unnecessarily
precisely and then slap it in the bowl
step 8 Korean Korea does not have a
system of measurements they don't go by
imperial they don't go by spoon is a
tablespoon or if it fits your mouth if
you measure you'll be wrong so don't
throw out your measuring cups
throw out your measuring bowls just
forget all of that because with the
NIH's the meat make meat a little tender
nice alright step 9 10 denies your meat
yes yes can either use a hammer or
pineapple yes now I actually do know
what you're talking about because in
pineapple is a chemical called bro
malaise or something like that and that
actually breaks down proteins so if you
eat enough pineapple you're inside of
your mouth will start to melt because
pineapple is eating away your mouth
it's literally dissolving your body so
it's just the same with me all in there
just eyeball it I love it
what is the plan here it's two pounds of
pineapple juice go in there to slice
slice onion slice
yes I'm gonna make like how much
step 13 all of them whatever you need to
know how much it's never enough they're
like no no that's creative way it cost a
meetings question
so you know enough to give us flavor
then with all kinds of just put it in
there you don't need to mince it just
make sure that all of it gets in there
that's what's important
which part is the top step 14 only cook
if you're meeting ten people or more
yeah that should probably be an earlier
step so people don't step 14 part b
korean recipes are only catered towards
families of ten or more you don't even
cook if you're not like grandma's house
it is like all the neighbors were just
growing vegetables like they were using
[Music]
okay most you don't I'm mushroom times
fifteen okay
you know why I'm doing this okay sixteen
the chunky has to go fine I'm just doing
it to help you okay no mushroom
mushrooms
slice it do I cut out the stammer i-i've
never prepared a mushroom in my life why
cuz I don't like
make sure you get your vitamins or you
die
[Applause]
place your bets now on whether or not
I'm going to cut my hand open live on
camera
you know Koreans don't know how to
measure things don't even try millimeter
yeah yeah okay two millimeters is what
you want and remember in Korean cooking
step eighteen you must be precise yeah
absolutely
Koreans will not accept imprecision step
nineteen I just lie
[Music]
I'm sure the only reason I'm going slow
is because I don't want to cut my what
is this baby food no you're wrong it's
garlic where'd you put your spoon
measuring spoon step 19 throw away your
table spoons you won't need them no yes
step 20 I lied again okay check step 24
B check to see if it's sample spoon by
putting it in your mouth one table
that's garlic 1 tablespoon rounded more
the better
Oh step 21 all the other steps were not
important but every step from 21 on
isn't it I want someone to write up all
these steps when this live stream is
done so that everybody can have a home
recipe of how to make fool what you say
oh if you want it to be a little - yeah
garlic brown yeah
step 22 it's expected that all your
ingredients should eventually just mix
together at any given moment
what is this real oil real oil oil
step 23 a real sesame none of that
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay roasted sesame see roasted and has
a little salt roasted put an assault you
can buy all this crap and the age of
market all this crap all this lovely
healthy food
oh yeah onion twice yes okay okay
I bought this what is the call please
son it's iodized sea salt
we're sorry inference eyelid I just see
yourself okay better look at this twice
more than we started cuz I
[Applause]
I have to first time in my life so I
don't like that you just stick the spoon
that has everything on it all the
ingredients I don't know how how much no
too much so this way 35 put some pepper
then throw a little salt just throw the
whole container
[Music]
cook in front of the life in my life
you're doing great I don't know you had
so much confidence at the beginning of
this and now it's all uncertainty you
need to get the confidence okay
that source is most important thing of
all 36 most important soy sauce soy
sauce I don't know but let's try let's
see by looking at the color of this meat
oh one is the one going in here get one
I'm going to use your hand
37 with my hands don't break it
just mix it softly gently mix that's 38
scratch that step 38 massage do not
break my precious meat step 30 point be
don't break the precious needs good I
guess this seems like a way more
involved bulgogi than you've ever made
before this is hamburger I never but
already
it's gonna stretch all this meat out
walking here step 39 if it turns out
hammer that's fine
so long as you could get a lot of Korean
cooking just as slapping things in a
bowl just seeing what happened that's
probably how kimchi came in all the crap
goes into the meat and wisdom go wash
your hands step 40's let it marinate
step 41 go wash your hands if you you
people do this or something 41 need more
prettier yeah so we're gonna what is
this okay all right now I looked up how
to cut a bell pepper because some people
were angry at me so apparently you got a
cut along the outside well I don't see
any you don't want to get this white
stuff in there I don't know something
like that no that's what I've read
people wrong step authority to you're
wrong everyone you're just wrong that's
the white one is most healthiest but
what the hell they're thinking I don't
know
I guess you know it if you're gonna
culture that's normally like any of the
food no step 47 one for color yeah
sliced this one as I said okay
winter yellow
it doesn't feel right it feels like I
should be doing a little more a little
more delicately step 47 never be
delicate with pretty why are you doing
[Music]
hey high 48
hi that's it all of this Rachel says
Merry Christmas been watching it for
years that I mostly look up you so much
hopefully you see this new and your
family of America Christmas and a Happy
New Year I hope you guys are following
at home we set out a blast of all the
ingredients that you need before this
live stream one live if you're not
following along at home then what are
you doing with your life my mom is very
disappointed in you step 49 the most
important step don't believe a word I
say now you take this first I take this
first yeah I'm gonna adjust it all right
we're gonna go for a little bit of a
ride everybody
if this falls down you don't know if
it's good enough at all okay
in the 100 about this
step 52 salty legs out the sweet just
explain what we're talking about now
mr. M said looks like some lowly food
have a Merry Christmas Merry Christmas
Eve for the mole where you put the
carrots and bell peppers together
carefully pick out 1054 carefully pick
out the peppers and the bowl that you
mixed all the you want the crust step 56
you want the crunch you want that's
impressive
I thought we are all gonna die you don't
need to time anything here
don't kill it
57 don't time it just look at it okay
leave it somewhere high 57
high heat first check it with the hand
[Laughter]
you know it's hot when your hands brown
like you know that sixty a thing pick a
random tool out of the bucket and use it
to scoop the meat with sixteen make sure
your pan is thick with three C's could
be a but it's not the boys doing the mom
fire fire
I need maybe even a wood stove with the
one stove tomato nice with friends when
you're just eyeballing it you don't need
fancy stoves or nothing you don't need
anything but your eyeballs your hands
and there's your mouth to check the
spoon sizes anything else is bunk
nobody needs it all line okay anything
else is just French okay and we're not
cooking French here probably an olive
oil
yeah Angelo's Grove that sounds Italian
one tape maybe wants to keep us along
happy person just as it warm I wouldn't
go around here I want like that so so it
does it does well these laughter that's
what you want okay okay
step six new one make sure it's sizzle
what in one out of time one scoop at a
time not too fast gently a little bit
I was always start spooning your meat
step 63 you know it's cooking when you
hear this sound old Korean secret
before
they should be following along at home
right now up to step 65 we haven't
gotten to step 65 yet but we're up to
spec 65 Hosea says Merry Christmas I
came into this country from Korea when I
was 21 and he couldn't hear they came
into America on December 10 when she was
21 and whether it was for the better for
the worse her life started over again
naturally I cannot say there was good at
the time I know it's a big baby big baby
10 pound 3 ounce baby you just said you
can cook on anything
it on so we're gonna 765 put a lid on it
and let it do the job let it do the job
yes today you'll have Google be right
and you know what when I introduce you
guys are food taster Co putting out food
taster Moe say oh I have photos they're
gonna be my food taster okay I start
wearing it under starve them okay my mom
is a habit of cooking real food for
those spoiling going on here no you
can't come over for dinner
Millie again you can at all also from
people s in the archive of this will be
posted I demand a write-up of every step
that we had thus far in triplicate by
the time this stream is ended which is
very soon now
well they don't trust you you know I
have a good reason in Korea they had a
she had a higher food taster and they
have before you King it the food taster
job was eating risking their life this
is my I'm almost ten year old my baby
[Music]
she's still strong that's one cute
Christmas sausage yeah that's a pretty
cute Christmas sausage has it done its
work everybody sniff as hard as they can
into their computer screens you can
smell it if you sniff hard enough let me
get up let me get a close-up of this and
you really need to appreciate the detail
what's going on here oh yeah there we go
oh I think they can hear the sizzling
sound oh there we go there we go smash
that like button for that sizzling sound
if you hear that sizzling sound smash
that like button you know that looks
good this is fruit authentic Korean
cooking with a true authentic Korean and
then a fake Korean myself I'm an
imitation curry you smell a sniff No
lift it snip-snip hard everybody sniff
sniff as hard as you can sniff see hmm
that's good that's good sniffing there
you go okay now I want to see if I can
put this back I think I broke the string
no that's fine okay it's okay it's
lagging look the Wi-Fi router is way
over there so if this dream is not
working on hundred percent it's it's
fine it's all ruined it
I am ruined
oh no I ruined it didn't I you did no I
think I ruined Oh Oh No oh you sniff too
hard ever
sniffing okay whatever it doesn't matter
okay it's fine let everybody listening
can you hear me good I think it's back
under control except that it's not so
remember this remember this one step 66
the last step it's for the power it's
for the color you know what I mean let's
make a little bit here okay step 66
six let's make it just a little prettier
[Music]
voila voila that's French you thought
wall dogs Korean step 67 voila is now
Korean this is a fact I'm not gonna pick
it up again because I know it's gonna
break I can bring it to them I just
wanna show them because I can't bring
the phone can you say that did you say
that I bet you did I bet you did I bet
you saw that or is it ready to taste
yeah all right guess you have to cook a
little longer it does look amazing
the stream is too real I don't know
sorry about the fact that this is like
cooking with their Korean parent or this
is just cooking in general or the smell
is just injecting into their
knows through the power that was a
positive oh no it was positive
yeah we see and Merry Christmas almost
not Christmas yet Christmas in Korea
it's Christmas in Korea so everybody in
Korea Merry Christmas
yeah my family Merry Christmas mm-hmm
yeah if you guys haven't gone out for
like Korean barbecue or something find a
good Korean barbecue place near you go
there it's always good wait you can
grill actually you can bring all this
stuff at the table yeah definitely go to
a place that has like the burner in the
middle of the table like if you've got
even probably everyone probably is a
friend that's been a Korean barbecue
have them take you out it's so much fun
you get to cook right on the grill right
there it's sometimes it's unlimited food
yeah but can I go to that one down yeah
yeah so we just gotta if you've got some
friend that knows Korean BBQ have them
take him out you have them take you out
and not only that if you order pop it to
dish they're putting on all the little
dishes
yes and rice - it's a Korean thing what
do you like to eat a lot of food just
like italiano
yeah more the better you all the wonders
and that with the own one they surprise
you comes with those extra swallows yeah
Korean always got side dishes side for
days you got bean sprouts rice you got
kimchi multiple kinds of kimchi cucumber
kimchi
you got that potato stuff you got
radishes you got top - no yeah depends
on the place but it's good food go on
we're gonna barbecue support your local
Korean barbecue restaurant today or this
Korean restaurant
you won't be disappointed step 68 you
won't be disappointed
spend all the Sun cookies I made no mom
has to first oh my this meat it's too
soft next time we're going to you don't
have to blame blame yourself you massage
too good you were the one that was
stabbing it I was there's video evidence
step 69 mom is never wrong sub 69 denied
denied denied salty no that's the major
thing let me taste were you just saying
there might not be enough salt there are
too much salt okay perfect perfect
longer me you know I'm gonna buy not the
already cheap one
yeah so long steak but one millimeter
one millimeter or two millimeter it
really just depends on how you're
feeling at that moment maybe a little
oh yes I'm sure
boys room ice go get someone else all
right
where should I reuse the spoon no no
that'd be gross yeah yeah right okay oh
yeah
oh my knee is getting some rice lovely
weather we're having you guys were
having a nice Christmas Eve cooking
adventure with me and my mom hey oh hey
I'll see you around
yeah yes I'm ready
what was the point of me getting it in
this bowl thank you all right I'm gonna
try this there's now a mukbang bang bang
away no I'm appointment it's from star
from Korean monkeys eat is eating me too
soft so soft but a cup of flavor
yeah the taste of good that meat sizzles
no 71 make sure your meat isn't dude
yeah they cooked with him 71 check to
make sure your meat is not too thin
before you start cooking step 72 make
sure you check step 71 before you've
even started this recipe that's very
important so meat five so long steak
honey at home yourself and then you need
more it's more like hamburger me
but other than that everything's good
mm-hmm I cannot complain the salt is
just enough baby really good you want to
put more soy sauce feel free to do so so
that is how cooking Korean food with my
mom smash that like button if you were
falling the recipe at home smash that
like button if you know that you want to
see this in the future smash that like
button for the reddit 5050 challenge
that I recorded with my mom yesterday
that's going to be without telling her
what its gonna be
so that's me being a bad son but thanks
so much for watching thank you mom for
showing the world how to make Korean
food properly the right way and as
always we'll see you in the next video
bye bye